Cloud Code can now remind you to do
things, check on things proactively for
you, and work for days straight without
you ever touching it or needing to give
any input. So, here you can see I just
said, "Remind me at 10:23 a.m. to check
on my project." It goes ahead and uses a
cron create tool to set this reminder.
There we go, 10:23 just hit. I didn't
touch it, and it just said, "Hey Nate,
this is your reminder to check on your
project." So, it just shot off this one
that says, "Every 10 minutes check my
ClickUp to see if there's any new
developments on our project." It's using
the loop skill, as you can see, which is
a new built-in skill, and it creates a
cron for every single 10 minutes. And
now this would run for the next 3 days
every 10 minutes until I told it not to.
And this doesn't have to be every 10
minutes. It could be every hour, it
could be every 5 minutes, it could be
whatever interval that you want. And
this is all thanks to the newly released
feature or skill loop, which is a
powerful new way to schedule recurring
tasks for up to 3 days at a time. And
this is so funny because less than 12
hours before this was announced, the
scheduled tasks in Cloud Code was also
announced. So, right off the bat, those
two features might seem like they're the
exact same thing, but they're actually
super different in how they work, and
they have different use cases. So, in
today's video, I'm going to break all of
that down and tell you everything that
you need to know about it. And by the
way, if you haven't watched my new
scheduled tasks video, then check that
out right up here. And then hop back
over to this one. All right, so as you
guys just saw in the quick demo, we now
have the ability to use loops, which
means that we could say something like
loop every 5 minutes check on
the deploy, or we could just say that in
natural language, which is awesome,
because it invokes the loop skill, and
then it creates that cron job right here
in Cloud Code. And you'll notice that
this is in my VS Code, so this is
available in your terminal, in Cloud
Code desktop app, in VS Code extensions,
wherever. This is just a core part of
Cloud Code now. So, if you're not seeing
this, just make sure you update your
extension or you update Cloud Code. And
this lets you set up loop intervals or
reminders. So, reminders, like you saw
that first demo, I just said, "Hey, at
this time, just tell me this." And in
that session, it will bump up a message
without you triggering it. Or you could
have them be intervals, so you could say
every 2 hours, you could say every 30
minutes, whatever you want that actual
interval to be. And what's cool about it
is it does it all in the same session.
So, if I leave this session up, every 10
minutes it would check everything right
here, which means that it's able to
continuously read through what happened
in the past one, and it continuously
sees what we're doing. Now, obviously
there are some pros and cons there, but
just wanted to point that out. The major
con there being your context, making
sure that if something does go off every
10 minutes, you're not going to get a
huge report, and then every 10 minutes
you just more tokens, more tokens, and
then context rot. It's basically
scheduling a prompt that you would be
sending in here and then firing off,
which means you can loop skills. So, if
you want every 20 minutes, for example,
run a skill called review PR, you could
tell it to every 20 minutes run the
skill.
It would run it, it would wait 20
minutes, and then it would do it again.
And of course, you could use actual
slash commands to invoke both the loop
and the skill, or you could just say
every 20 minutes run my review PR skill.
And of course, the one-time reminder
feature, so at 3:00 p.m. or in 45
minutes, remind me to do this or check
in on that. And Claude will basically
pin that time, it'll create that cron,
and then once it's done, it'll just
delete itself. So, with that, let's say,
"Hey, at 4:30 remind me I have to go do
this." or every hour remind me to just
stand up and like look away from my
screen for 5 minutes,
it can do that. All right, so there's a
couple things that I wanted you guys to
understand about how this actually
works. So, let's just play around a
little bit. Hey, at 10:40 a.m., can you
please remind me to take out the
garbage?
Cool. So, what that's going to do is
it's going to use the cron create tool,
and it's going to create that basically
schedule to remind me take out the
garbage.
And what you can see here is the actual
prompt. So, at this interval, which is
just how cron works, it's basically
going to shoot a prompt into this window
that says remind Nate to take out the
garbage. You can see the recurring
equals false. Now, of course, the key is
if the session is closed, then that cron
is going to automatically be killed. So,
now something interesting. I'm going to
open up a new session, and I'm going to
say,
"Hey, every hour can you just remind me
I need to stretch my neck."
And I'm going to shoot this one off, and
we'll see how this one is a little bit
different. Because this once again
creates a cron, we have a prompt, and
you can see in this one we don't have
the recurring equals false. We just know
that this cron is going to go every
hour. But, these loop jobs or task jobs
are per session. So, these two tabs are
two different sessions. So, if I came
into this session and said, "Can you
please tell me all of the scheduled loop
tasks that we have today?"
It's going to use a tool called cron
list, and it only can see the 10:40 a.m.
take out the garbage. It cannot see the
task that exists in this session because
they're independent and they're
separate.
Now, one interesting thing to notice is
that this session didn't actually invoke
the loop tool. The loop tool basically
tells it how to set up cron jobs and how
to use the cron create. So, if you don't
see loop, don't worry, it's still
actually doing this in a loop. It's just
kind of about the actual wording. So, if
I was to open a new one, let's see if I
actually call the loop tool right here.
So, I do loop, and then I just say, you
know, um
check my ClickUp. This one is going to
default, I believe, to 10 minutes if you
don't specify a time, and it might
invoke the loop skill because we
actually called it, too. But, looks like
it didn't because it knows exactly what
it needs to do already. So, the point
being, all that matters is that the cron
is being created. It doesn't always
matter if it invokes the loop skill or
not. And then, if you wanted to cancel
one of these jobs, all you'd have to do
is either close out of the terminal or
just say, "Actually, I don't need this
anymore. Go ahead and cancel it."
And that one invokes a different cron
skill called cron delete. It shoots over
the job ID, and now that it's canceled.
And one final thing to keep in mind is
in VS Code, if you close out of a tab
and then you just open up that
conversation again, that still will kill
those crons. So, you guys just saw how
pretty much all of this worked. We have
cron create to schedule, we have cron
list to list them, and then we have cron
delete to cancel them, and all of those
can be invoked with natural language,
which is awesome. So, now let's get into
some of the limitations, and then I'm
going to compare them to the actual
scheduled tasks feature. So, the first
big one is that we have a 3-day loop
expiry, which is just basically for
safety. It auto cleans things up if you
forgot you had all of these loops
running. So, once you create a loop, it
basically has a 3-day timer on it. It
can run for day one, it can run on day
two, and then on day three it can run up
until that last fire, and then it will
auto delete. And if you want anything
longer than 3 days, then you would
either just recreate that loop, or that
probably indicates that you should just
turn this into a legitimate scheduled
task. Now, the other thing that you can
do is if you wanted to completely
disable scheduling, so maybe in your
natural prompting it's accidentally
creating all these crons, you could go
into your environment variables and just
disable that. And it would probably be
able to help you figure that out. So,
the other things here are that if you
close the terminal, your tasks are gone.
It doesn't have catch-up, so the
scheduled tasks, if you, you know,
opened up your desktop app and you
missed a bunch, it would catch up
automatically. This doesn't do that. And
there's no persistence, meaning after
your 3 days and you wanted to do that
same loop again, it would be a fresh
session. But obviously there's tons of
things you can do here with context
management and reading different files
in order to kind of Frankenstein your
own fix there. So, now that all the
features have been explained and you've
seen a demo, I think that probably you
understand the difference between the
loop and the scheduled tasks a bit
better now, but let's just go over some
of the key highlights. The loop has your
3-day expiry, it's all done within one
session, and there's no catch-up. It's
basically a help me now or help me on
this project for today type of function.
The scheduled tasks are disk-stored,
they're long-lived, they have catch-up,
and these are like daily, weekly,
monthly functions that can run
indefinitely. Of course, with both of
these though, the terminal or, you know,
the app has to be open, and this one is
only currently available in the desktop
app, but I can imagine with how fast I
drop it shipping things, maybe by the
time you watch this video, scheduled
tasks are already out for the terminal
and extensions as well, the way that
loop is available in Cloud Code
Everywhere. So, basically, it's one
simple question. Do you need help right
now on a project, or do you need help
with something every day or every week?
And that's how you decide if you use the
new loop feature or if you use scheduled
tasks. So, I thought I'd end off real
quick by giving a few, maybe practical
ways that you could actually use loop
rather than something scheduled. So,
maybe all day you're waiting on a very
urgent email. Just set up Cloud Code to
check in on that email every 5 minutes.
And if it's there, it can automatically
let you know. Maybe you're working on a
deploy and you want to just pull that
and check every, you know, hour or so if
everything's working okay. Maybe you've
got a deadline due at the end of the
week and you need a 3-day sprint to be
constantly checking in on the team and
checking in on progress. Maybe you're
testing and iterating. Maybe you're
watching logs. Maybe you're tracking
changes. There's so many different use
cases here. There's so many different
ways to use the Loop to prompt an agent,
to have different files, to use
different skills. And it's really,
really cool the way that you could
potentially set these things up. But now
that you understand all of the power
with these Loops, the next step that I
would recommend is trying to build your
own executive assistant. So, I just
dropped a full video about how that
works. You can watch that one right up
here. So, hopefully I see you guys over
there. But that's going to do it for
today. So, if you enjoyed and you
learned something new, please give it a
like. That really helps me out a ton.
And as always, I appreciate you guys
making it to the end of the video. I'll
see you on the next one.
Thanks, everyone.